all right we're gonna send out the first
person
you're the kind of teenager I'm a little
afraid of you
my name is billery and I'm a fashion
designer and hand embroidery artist my
name is Jess I have been a professional
Fashion Stylist for seven years now
what's up guys I'm Casey and I also have
been a wardrobe status and Creator
director for about 15 years now how
would you describe gen Z fashion Tick
Tock I think it's emotionally charged
people dressed how they feel typically
based on what they take in content-wise
or music that they hear I work for a gen
Z catered fashion brand right now and
it's heavily Trend focused Cottage core
mermaid core alt it's inspired by
Netflix shows like Wednesday items and
like artists like Olivia Rodrigo things
like that it's constantly changing it's
very Niche and things go in and out of
style very quickly a big red flag for me
right now is um socks
a lot of big appreciation for like a
clean pair of socks now yeah it's funny
all right we're gonna send out the first
person
I say my style is more formal 80s-esque
and fitted my style stems from some Tick
Tock definitely Tyler the Creator and
then my grandpa I steal a lot of his
clothes I'm just like a younger version
of him
[Music]
so very put together I guess I'm like
more into like Cottage core like skirts
and like the puff sleeves and like the
bows and the hair
I would say Y2K emo Rock
the OPM label group and I used to escape
growing up so that's a big influence too
mid-century eras so 50s 60s even 70s I
draw a lot of inspiration from like
older photos and also I sew so I have
like a collection of vintage patterns
just watching my grandparents and my mom
watching them put clothes on and just
dress nice it kind of just wanted to
make myself just go out there and be
more presentable
[Music]
say mine is always changing and
generally very girly
I'm definitely a Pinterest person like
anywhere where I get the time I'll just
beyond I'm just on Pinterest
I would describe my style as adventurous
definitely groovy and Thrifty two
because I love thrifting 90s fashion 60s
too because I like bell bottoms really
groovy really funky those type of vibes
[Music]
hey I'm Josh and I'm the director of
this episode of ranking if you like this
video make sure to like And subscribe
now let's get back to the ranking I
think we were shocked I learned a few
things learned a few things everyone was
their own individual it's like I I fully
saw who they were like I saw an art
teacher I saw the rock star I saw you
know the young cool uncle they look like
they know who they are based off of how
they dress at that age I was probably
still figuring it out yeah so I can say
like the overexposure to all the
different styles on the internet might
be good because they can just pick the
one that they want versus just kind of
just following the crowd at school or
something like that yeah so guys
okay what are we gonna do yeah so
Sebastian for me what really stood out
was the jewelry it's very Dapper he was
the most elevated yeah he's a front
runner for me he surprised me at the
consistency I like it and this tie that
he did for the nighttime look was really
nice too high scarf absolutely Alyssa I
think she was the one that was giving me
somewhat modern Gossip Girl because it
was like girly and dainty she's a class
president yeah she gave us Tears like a
sheer sleeve and a chunky comfortable
boot pair with a sheer sock and sock
they did well with the smokes
um I will say I don't want to be like
super in the details but her
undergarments didn't quite go with the
top and they were like showing and then
like she had her hair tie on and like
small things that I feel like yeah
weren't thought of all right next up we
have Kane Rockstar I'm scared of a man
early 2000s Ed Hardy limp biz yeah like
he's like Motley Crue all the things
gives teenage angst like he embodies an
era that will never go away he fully
carried it out in his attitude it was a
performance really yeah yeah
next up we got emojis
wow that was the first thing I saw this
you know that's her style because that's
not a 16 year old style yeah yeah yeah
and maybe here I would have done a black
boot I feel like the brown boot is kind
of a part of her whole like Farm Cottage
corn like peeled back wearing their
mom's clothes from when correct she she
got all of these from her you know that
these have traveled through oh they have
a family correct for sure like heirlooms
all right now we got big Bryant all
right
this is my he's good at simple color
coordination statement piece but still
not doing too much not too much and and
taller guys usually stray away from
anything that'll bring them too much
attention but I hate this word and hate
saying it but the swag of it all was
absolutely present it's like the pins
transition into the shoes for the
nighttime look I really like that that's
my boy now with the shoes I would have
kept the shoe more simple so that it was
all about that pant so you can get into
that that design and that pattern my
main thing was again jewelry just needed
like one step more yeah I agree with
that ananya those corsets are her thing
and corsets are kind of hard to get away
with and be age-appropriate but she
pulls it off wow oh my gosh just
realized that Fairy come in I don't even
want to know what I wear at 14. in the
baggy jean and the in the chunky shoe
it's it's a it's a mesh of Worlds here
um her nighttime look very much so gave
me the craft I don't know if y'all seen
that movie another play on socks for you
I'm telling you they were listening
Noble
daytime look took it for me yeah the
denim patches that didn't skirt she also
kind of has her own type of teenage
angst cyberpunk yeah
did you see her jibbit in her Croc was
it crochet it was I saw that I saw that
I loved the olive earring the olive top
and the olive pants everything was was
very very cohesive she doesn't stray
away from who she is
okay I'll walk over here no no no
no spot
or out of it I feel good so this is kind
of hard to do because like you guys are
like have your own personality in each
of your own Styles and I really love it
I don't know that's I can't rank you
guys are so I would put you here
wait this is the top yeah oh no
you need to say like top three at the
very least because you she crocheted
this she yeah
the colors that you're wearing as well
are just so cohesive yeah I guess I
don't know what it'd be like yeah do it
do it
all right
it's got like character I love it I know
like his pants are just like so unique
and I just love them
you I put you second only because it's
it's not very common for me to see guys
dress up like I'm used to seeing the
girls standing outside I will put you I
will put you second that's why I'm
moving behind him okay so hot take I
just don't want that to like downplay
like the the women in this room that
have like amazing style like I think
that you two are like icons just because
there's a dude in the room I don't think
that we should like have that outweigh
all of the intention and all of the
thought that was put into both of your
guys's looks but I also that's not to
downplay like you look amazing amazing
and I also like think that like you have
such I feel like you are like a picture
that you see online like when they're
looking up you embody like what you're
trying to go for like you're so true
oh my God
definitely but I also I really like
women's
I feel like he should stay at the front
I think you need to be hired I'm so good
I don't see your style like ever that's
so thoughtful and I really appreciate it
but I'm comfy here I I know I look great
like seriously I'd love to see you hire
but I also like
this is like a single file line
all right guys so like you said nobody
is the least here we were extremely
Blown Away by everyone's Style
considering you know you all's age and
when we grew up we did not look like
this for you guys to come out here and
really just play individuality in like
such confidence and such energy it was
great
um so we have uh Alyssa Alyssa we chose
you because we personally feel like you
were very sweet it was it was
um easily fadable if that makes sense I
love all the colors you chose
okay so for number six we have ananya I
was proud I liked it you were one of my
favorites I do think that your nighttime
look is a little daytime ish but I like
the age-appropriateness of the corsets
and how you put that together because it
was really cute thank you
okay so for number five we have Noble I
love the attention to detail it is just
a little bit more trendy of an outfit so
it's not as Timeless in my opinion but I
still think it's really strong and
cohesive and we loved your attitude
behind your presentation as well thank
you my boy Brian
oh then he got a little gold so I work
with LeBron James's family his wife I'm
her stylist and when you came out it
just reminded me of how all the NBA
players come out the tunnel and get
those style shots and I would I was
telling them I was like I had to pick
anybody to like style to steal it would
be yours I love the edginess I love the
cleanliness I love the choices
everything was cool all right number
three we have Imogen
we love your style looks like very much
so you like you really know how to
prepare a good picnic and have a good
time I feel art teacher I felt when you
came out I felt warm I felt safe felt
like these pieces came from your family
lineage like their heirloom
number two is Kane I personally loved
how everything is thought out how you
cut your jeans to lay on your shoe
better with the fur underneath the
layering of the belts your accessories
your nails are done we just love like
the performance you gave honestly just
like sitting in that like angstiness was
like really cool yeah you're the kind of
teenager I'm a little afraid of you but
I like that though I like it it's every
time you walked out but I still
remembered you I still was like dang
like I wonder what you have to like I
don't really care what the judges are
going to say about it
yeah the attention to detail the nails
but uh last but totally not least our
guy our number one our number one
Sebastian I feel like you could exist
anywhere I feel like you could work in
Paris you can work in Milan you could
work in New York like you are very well
layered well tiered into Who You Are
yeah like you've been here before you
dress like you read good books
job interview but you could also wear it
to a first date so it's very much so
like put together clean there's a lot
thank you very good
confidence and individuality is
everything to me always take your
individuality over everything teaspoons
of reference
tablespoons of yourself and make your
punch